We are here celebrating the first day of
classes at the Colegio del Sur de Navarra
and we hope that we will have about 34,000
students who are going to enter today to begin
their college studies. Of course, 30
percent of the students are Hispanic.
teachers who are
bilingual we have
workers who speak Spanish here we are
all here to serve you and well I want you to
know that you are safe this is a
safe environment here the most important thing is the
safety of the students the health of the
students is that we have the example of the
Basque the wta that we are using wash
their hands safely and apart from
that the studies of the studies are
programmed for the students who
can get jobs or to
continue their university studies in all
three cases of course yes so no
it does not matter which of the fields
the students will be there we will have the
services verify that no this semester
the vaccine is not required see  Dad, but it
is required for the following semester,
which is very important that
they get their vaccinations by November, please,
please let them register, there
is still time, we are here until September 5,
thank you very much,
goodbye.